welcome and hello everyone
my name is mira debs and i am the
executive director
of yale's education studies program
we're so glad that you're here
the yale education studies program is an
interdisciplinary community
that empowers students and researchers
to critically examine
and collectively reshape the education
landscape
through research policy and practice
in our conversation this evening over
the next hour we're going to focus on
the role of student activism and the
media
in addressing educational injustice and
specifically
the enduring school segregation in new
york city
the nation's largest school district
home to 1.1 million students
new york city has an elaborate school
choice system
primarily for middle and high school
students with
a lot of schools that have screened
admissions
where student test scores student grades
gpas attendance sometimes
interviews and portfolios are all
factored into admissions decisions
there also is a gifted and talented
program
and there's a test for that starting
when students are four years old
so as a result of of these screens an
enduring problem in new york city is
that the most
elite schools are disproportionately
white and asian in a district that is
majority black
and latinx students and so as you'll
learn this evening
students have been fighting for over 50
years to integrate new york city schools
in 1964 the largest civil rights
demonstration
during the civil rights movement 464 000
students participated in a walkout
protesting the segregated schools of new
york city
and in the last decade the topic of
school integration
with the help of student activists from
organizations including teens take
charge
and integrate new york city have been
integral
in pushing this issue back to the center
of the education agenda
the students have also focused not only
on integration
but educational self-determination in
empowering students
to determine alongside with their
communities and equitable future
you may be wondering why focus on school
integration right now or in the middle
of
a pandemic many schools are closed
students are out of school
so why this issue right now
as i've heard repeatedly from students
and parents
and i'm currently doing research with
molly mackris
and elise castillo on on this topic
this issue is only more urgent right now
the pandemic has made inequality between
neighborhoods and between communities
and schools even more apparent there is
no going back
to the way things were and in the last
two months
there has been some significant progress
in terms of announcements
from the mayor and the school's
chancellor regarding
middle school screens some high school
admissions and a change to the gifted
and talented test
so there's momentum and change happening
right now even in the middle of the
pandemic
um a few notes on logistics before we
get started
um our panel discussion is going to run
about 35 minutes
and then we will have time for questions
and you can submit a question at any
time
via the q a tab in the bottom of your
screen
and it is now my honor to
pass the baton to our moderator sarah
medina commissioner
sarah is a third year law student at
yale
she's a lecturer at in the education
studies program
and she's also one of the adult founders
of integrate new york city
and for that reason sarah is a living
representation of the nexus of
research policy and practice which is
core to the ed studies program
so thank you so much sarah
yeah thank you mira hail this is such a
gift
to be with you all today i'd like to
kick us off
as we tend to do in the youth organizing
space with setting some intentions
and so the intentions i've set for today
and gotten consent from our panelists
for
are one to create an intergenerational
discussion
on self-determined movement building and
resistance for integration and
structural equity
so what does that mean for you in the
audience
and what does that mean for our
panelists it means that i
ask that you listen deeply and write
questions
comments ideas when you feel animated or
curious
this work does not move without
interaction
and exchange the second
is to build a robust diverse network
of students organizers academics and
researchers
who elevate students and families to
build authentic integration and
anti-racist education
as they see it so that all people may
thrive
to that end i ask that you consider the
unique
strengths of each person here the school
integration movement
cannot happen with each per without each
person here
and consider the ways that you might
provide resources
networks expertise to support anyone
here
and at the end when we ask you to take
action i
ask that you do it in exchange for the
hour that folks here have given with
their wisdom
and their story so to kick it off
i would love for our panelists to
introduce themselves
name pgp the organization
you are representing here today your
role in it
and how did you start working in the
school integration space
and i'll popcorn it to someone as you
tend to do in the organizing space and
have
them popcorn to someone else annette i
will ask you to kick it off for us
hey y'all um my name is annette my
pronouns are
she her hairs i'm part of instagram nyc
my role is co-founding director
and um the way i got started i've
actually been working with integra nyc
for five years now
and i got involved through a school
exchange that my school did
with bronx letters um yeah i'll popcorn
it
to orion
hey everybody my name is o'brien um
pronouns he him his
um i'm a director and youth coach with
integrate nyc and i got involved three
years ago
in 2018 when i attended a rally for the
fair play
coalition regarding sports equity and
i've been
involved with the work ever since and
i'll popcorn it to alex
hi everybody my name is alex rodriguez
my pronouns are open
and i guess you can say my role in teen
sake charges an alumni coach
and um my involvement with um youth
activism is quite an expansive story
but i guess most simply put it all
started in a conversation with my really
good friend sokonjara
in a forever 21 of all places and we
just started kicking it off and talking
about our experiences in school
and then next thing you know i'm in a
wonderful organizing space with other
youth
of color and then i'll pass it on to
ayanna
hi my name is ianna smith my producer
she her hers
um like alex i graduated out of teens
take charge so i'm kind of serving as an
alumni coach now
i think my story with school integration
and just education justice work
begins probably in my ninth grade when i
learned about the achievement gap um
i was really motivated to act and do
something about it but i didn't have the
platform at the time
and then one day one of my close friends
said hey you should join teams take
charge
it seems like it's something to be
interested in and from there i've been
involved in the organization and doing
a ton of bad justice work
nah oh the next it's a real pledge to
have a chance to speak with all you this
evening
i'm matt delmont professor of history at
dartmouth college
i guess my involvement with school
immigration began as an observer
i'm involved in the open enrollment
program in minneapolis in 1980s when i
was in elementary school
as a researcher i'm interested in the
history of civil rights and always have
been interested in how our schools
became segregated and how people fought
back against that
have done work on philadelphia new york
city boston chicago
it's real pleasure to have a chance to
make connections between history and the
present day
on the panel this evening back to you
sir
thanks matt so we have incredible
blessing of a panel here today
and so i'm really excited to get into
things what i'm curious about
is why our audience hasn't asked
questions such as
where is this amazing forever 21 where
all these student organizers begin
their careers or what is a school
exchange
again given the virtual world that we're
in we're going to rely on folks to
really have active question making so
feel free to start popping those
questions in
okay so my first the first couple
questions and thanks folks for all the
questions that are coming in
um professor debs is going to be
moderating them
um they're gonna the first question is
from mr delmont
take us back to the new york city
activism that you cover
in your book why bussing failed what
were the demonstrations of students and
parents
and how were they covered by the media
thanks sarah for that question um so as
professor debs mentioned there was a
massive school boycott in 1964 the
largest protest in the history of civil
rights
460 000 students stay out of school to
protest
a school segregation in new york city
what's interesting about the story in
new york is it it's really had been
going on for a whole decade prior to
that so
usually when we were taught about the
history of school segregation school
integration
it's usually a southern story uh but the
story of new york city is really a
parallel story to that to
the southern story so in the early 1950s
ella baker the famous civil rights
organizer
is the president of the new york branch
of the naacp
and she's working with kenneth clark the
famous psychologist to organize parents
and civic leaders to really protest the
kind of extreme inequality they see
in the city's public schools they know
that black and latinx students
are going to schools that are under
resourced they know that a lot of these
textbooks in the schools
have racist texts and racist images and
they want the students to be able to go
to schools that have
equal equal resources and are equitable
um that happens even before the brown
versus board decision when brown versus
board is decided by the supreme court in
1954
activists in new york say why not here
right the decision is focused on
southern schools but they see they look
all around they see that schools in new
york are equally segregated and they
demand
action they demand action through
um public protests through editorials
and through statements at school board
meetings
because they're trying to bring this
issue into the public for a lot of folks
in new york at that time
they just didn't believe that school
segregation educational inequality could
be
issues in new york they thought this is
a liberal progressive place these kind
of issues only happen in the south they
can't actually happen in new york city
so they're trying to push it out in the
open
in 1957 the same year as the little rock
school integration crisis
there's a group of mothers in new york
who file a lawsuit against the school
board to protest
educational inequality and they hold
their children out of school for months
in protest
this is a boycott that risks jail time
and the black press dubbed them the
harlem nine so to play on the little
rock nine right so this is going on the
exact same time what's going on in the
south
these protests continue and escalate in
the late 1950s early 1960s
reverend milton glamison a woman named
annie stein lead a group called the
parents workshop for equality
and they threatened as early as 1960 a
large-scale boycott
because they're just calling on the
school board to do something meaningful
to aggressive school segregation
over this entire period from 1954 to
1964 the school board makes
only really small changes so they might
move a few hundred students from an
overcrowded school in the bronx to
a bus crowded school in queens but
mostly the school board drags their feet
they refuse to acknowledge that school
segregation is a real issue they refuse
to take any meaningful steps
and even those small scale changes are
met with intense resistance from white
parents
who frankly want to maintain the status
quo they want to maintain racial
segregation in the schools
so by february 1964 when this massive
school boycott takes place civil rights
activists have been fighting the school
board for more than a decade
and they have little to show for it so
they're they're exhausted they're
frustrated and they
demand that this is the time that action
is finally going to take place um that
boycott itself brings together a
coalition of different groups both kind
of more moderate groups more
more militant groups it's something that
doesn't really get taught in the same
way in our our textbooks because
the media at the time particularly the
white media things like the new york
times
disregards that kind of protest they
call it a violent uh
act of uh adult adult encouraged truancy
and so it's not treated with the same
kind of sense of urgency as the civil
rights protests are going on in
montgomery
selma and little rock at the same time
and so i think for me what's important
about that story
about school integration in the the
civil rights activism in new york city
is that parents students were intensely
organized and they were trying to fight
to make this an issue that would be
be acknowledged but the school board at
every turn tried to push back
and maintain the status quo of
segregation
thanks matt i have another question here
and then folks i'm going to be turning
it over to our
student activists here on the panel to
ask any follow-up questions
um and if not i'll probably jump into
some questions that i'm seeing in the
chat but
um what did people understand the story
to be about desegregation and what would
you say is the most important
misunderstanding that you wanted to
disrupt in your book
yes one of the things that's fascinating
about this history in
in the north is there's a sense that it
was optional
so sometimes people will talk about the
history of segregation north and say it
was de facto
that it was somehow by customer by
market forces and this segregation
school stargating in places like new
york chicago boston it was intentional
um school boards drew zoning lines in
ways that would purposely create
schools that were predominantly latino
predominantly white predominantly
african-american
but they did it in such a way that they
kind of hid the racist intent of it
which made it very very difficult for
activists to bring these cases into
court and to actually get justice
and to to finally get some some actual
integration in the schools
so one thing they tried to show in the
book was that these protests over school
desegregation
um they really needed to when we think
about them in the north we need to think
about them with the same sense of moral
urgency
as we tend to think about school
segregation in the south that the
over the years the debate has really
been um switched in such a way that
all the focus becomes on the
perspectives and desires of
white parents whereas when we're talking
about school integration what we should
be focusing on is the rights and
educational outcomes
for black and latinx students
thanks matt um do any of our student
activists here
have any questions i feel like in
particular
brought up some of the untold stories of
mostly black and puerto rican student
organizers in new york city
um anyone want to ask any questions
i had a question not that i wanted to
follow up on
why do you feel like it's often such an
untold story
that the largest civil rights
demonstration
was a half million black and puerto
rican students in new york
what do you think is driving that story
not being covered and not being made
front and center
at the time when it happened and today
because i'm sure
a lot of people on this call are like
wait a minute let me fact check that
the largest civil rights demonstration
was black and puerto rican students in
new york city
i think that's right yeah i think the
reason didn't get attention at the time
and the reason it hasn't gotten much
attention until
recently um is that it's it's a more
uncomfortable and difficult story for a
lot of people particularly folks in the
north to reckon with
um what i mean by that is it was easier
for people for white folks
in 1964 whether that's the parents the
school board or or media
to point to places in the south and say
well that's that's bad things that are
happening in the south that's where
racism exists it exists
down in montgomery and down in selma it
can't possibly exist
in new york in new york that's
to actually think about that history
honestly it forces people to reckon with
the the privilege they have
in their own neighborhoods in terms of
housing in terms of schools
and it actually forces them to give up
something so one of the things that
martha king would always say when he
came to speak in new york city and other
places in new york was
that white liberals and white moderates
had to actually live up to their ideals
it wasn't enough to be liberal when we
were talking about race just in the
south you had to be a liberal when it
actually came to your own neighborhood
into your own backyard i mean i think
that was true in the 60s i think it's
true today it's it's hard
there's a willful ignorance that a lot
of people like to have about the
realities of racism in our country
i think that's particularly true in
places that people want to think of as
being somehow more progressive or more
liberal
it allows them to not deal with the
actual reality of how race is structured
in our country
i actually have one follow-up question
for you and then i'm going to pass along
the folks here
i heard you say asking folks to be
liberal in their own neighborhoods
it almost sounds to me like the word
liberal and anti-racist or being
interchanged in that in that statement
can you maybe elaborate a little bit
more for me around how you understand
conservativism
versus liberalism in this conversation
and when they do
and don't um become words that can be
replaced one another
sure that that's a big question so think
about the the time period i'm studying
historical time period
um conservatives would have been more
directly outspoken and say
i'm thinking of folks like barry
goldwater the senator from arizona who
was explicitly opposed to the civil
rights
act right he didn't he thought it was
unconstitutional he didn't think that
the government had a role to play in
uh in promoting immigration so i think
conservatives in that time period were
more vocal in their opposition
liberals white liberals in this case had
a position where they would say they
were in favor of integration
generally but when push came to shove
they did everything they could to not
actually integrate their own
neighborhoods in their own schools
and so i think that's a a sort of
a structuring reality about how um
white wibblism has functioned in our
country is that it's liberal
in sort of general strokes but not
actually uh
in practice when actually comes to
things that directly impact people's
lives
um the term anti-racist didn't exist in
the 60s but i think
part of what king was calling for was
people to be proactive to take the
action
actions that would follow up on their
their ideals right and so i think
to transpose it into the present i think
the the kind of things we see taking
place in new york city right now
right it's doesn't do much good to say
you're in favor of
educational equality if you're not
actually going to support proactively
support
the policies and the steps that are
going to produce those outcomes on the
ground
thanks so much folks um i'm gonna move
to
our integrated myc and teens take charge
folks
um but want to give folks here an
opportunity to possibly ask any
questions any follow-up
to matt
okay um i also just want to shout out i
see
a lot of folks in the chat from
integrated schools uh such a blessing to
be with you all today
um so i want to first start off
you know matt talks a lot in his book
about busing
and how bussing becomes the thing that
people talk about
is segregation and is the issue around
immigration and
that's the real issue and why we have to
remain segregated i'm wondering if we
could start maybe with
integrated nyc first and talking about
in 2014 and 2015
when y'all first started how was
what was the busing of the time what was
the thing that people told you
integration was um and what were the
ways that you had to really push against
that
to create the five r's
um i think buzzing was still a thing for
us like maybe not busing busing but just
like
the movement of bodies and maybe like
enrollment was only talked about when we
first started
and the quick solution was sort of seen
as
well if we just make the schools look
different
that will solve the problem or if we
make them look desegregated
that will solve the problem but i don't
think um
the people making this policy well it's
not i don't think i know that the people
making this policy didn't think
about what students felt and experienced
every single day because
us students it was so obvious for us to
see that
enrollment wasn't the only issue and
enrollment wasn't
the only solution either and so that's
why
when we began our youth councils and
meeting with students all across
the five boroughs we created the five
r's um
we first like talked about our
experiences and i saw somebody ask like
what a school exchange is and
um for us it's basically like when you
like buddy up with someone
in the other school you know you have a
group of of students kind of buddying
each other up and
you take each other through the through
your day in your school
and for all of us that community and
relationship work was really important
um because it allowed us to see each
other's experiences and then
have similar conversations with other
students from other schools around the
city
and um that's kind of how we came about
our 5r
platform which is race and enrollment so
yes let's let's address
race and enrollment right and actually
name like race and what are
what are other factors that we are
taking into account when enrolling
students because that shouldn't be the
only thing
um and like how do we use those factors
to like benefit students rather than
like penalize them um for stuff that has
happened in their lives we have
um resources which talks about how like
resources are added up are allocated um
inequitably
across like schools some schools get to
any sports teams other schools get
zero some schools get three science labs
others get like broken lab equipment
um and we talk about representation
which
talks about like um how which really
addresses that like a lot of our
um our teachers and a lot of the people
who are teaching us
stuff and and like in front of the
classroom are white and don't look like
most black and brown like students
um and and like don't really like are
not able to identify and connect with
them in that way so like how
how are we addressing that issue as well
um we talk about relationships which is
like
okay once we're all in the building and
we're um
in a diversified space like what does
that mean like how do we build
relationships together like how we're
not just gonna ignore like all the
tension and like the history of like
trauma that our families like our
individual families are in our
individual bodies have gone through
and we also have restorative justice
which um
it's the last rmc breath there's five
r's
um i also want to invite o'brien if you
want to add anything for
in those hours our last one is
restorative justice which deals with
um the school of prison pipeline which
like
shows that a lot of our students and
especially our black and brown students
are being like locked up and are being
isolated from
um maybe perhaps the only institution
that could give them like a meet like
like any kind of stability um and and so
like what
what does restorative justice look like
and how do we like really
build um a community where we can learn
from our mistakes and not like punish
students especially like
a black and brown students
thanks so much annette um i'd love to
hear a little bit
from teens take charge about the way
that you've disrupted media
and the way that you've used new media
new ways to address media the way that
the podcast has done that
and really shifted um the the way that
young people are like matt was saying
push to the side
in the narrative about integration what
are the innovative ways that you've
really transformed how students are
centered
um in mainstream media
yeah i think that brings up a really
good point um when talking about how
the north has was kind of seen as this
like holy grail
and to this day it's like very much we
see a lot of dare i say like
neocolonization of terms like
progressive
and um democrat or liberal
and what we find is a lot of parents
especially parents were opposed to
integration and kind of
use these as almost shields to protect
them from their own racist
tendencies when talking about education
and so what teams take charge has been
doing a lot of
is trying to infiltrate as much as the
media as possible
to kind of make these problems known
it's been swept under the rug for
literally decades right
and we know that like if there's
anything that our generation
can do is completely infiltrate the
media and so
we made sure to center as much student
voices as possible because those are
undisputable at least i hope to be
right and so with the podcast you know
we're
talking about the in-person experiences
that different students have
had different um underfunded
institutions and things like that that's
one way
we've been so fortunate to have plenty
like a couple of documentaries
and about student experiences and their
different um
intersectional experiences about living
in a extremely segregated school system
but also just like things like instagram
and
twitter um that has also been really
fundamental at educating
you know our following our followers you
know and reaching
all over the place because i mean it's
everywhere right how can we engage with
our audience in a more personal level
um when we do these types of like um
media campaigns
hashtags and things like that as well
yeah um wow every time i hear about the
media i just get really excited
um as teens take charge as former
co-director press
because i like that was my life from the
year that i was involved in an
organization before graduating
and i feel like in my experience adding
on to what alex said
definitely the media has been important
during the conversation and bringing
light to it but i feel like
um at least when i published my first
op-ed it was a really like personal
experience i remember
walking into school the next day and my
principal like stopping me in the
hallway and asking me about like school
integration in my work and like praising
my op-ed
um and she shared it with other teachers
and students within the school and that
started a school-wide discussion about
like school integration for around a
week or so
and like every time i published
something new it was featured in
something
um students and teachers together we'd
kind of just learn from each other's
experiences when we had the free time
to engage in that um so storytelling is
definitely a big part of
youth organizing around school
integration and um
it really does like start conversations
and allows people to change the
narratives and
um come together and just like create a
new understanding and vision for
education in the future so
yeah thank you so much
i have a conversation i've appreciated a
couple comments in the chat because
oftentimes what people are looking at is
what's in the media
but not knowing about what's actually in
the movement and the way that we have to
work to heal
each other and support each other and so
um
i wanted to get more on a personal level
to really give folks here
this is a form of media arguably right
um
the opportunity to to just really
appreciate
what the folks here are are doing and
the
many lonely challenging moments outside
of the exciting meetings
or the inspiring time at forever 21
there's a lot of lonely times
when you wonder do i want to take that
risk do i want to deal with people in
the internet making racial slurs at me
do i want to deal with my classmates or
parents putting me down
and so i'd like to ask this first
question it comes from
one of our students who said what is the
moment that you felt
segregation in your body that you
actually felt the experience
what did it feel like where were you and
would you be willing to share a little
bit with the group here
i can go first um so i went to a
specialized high school i went to
brooklyn technical high school
and you know that school is like
quote unquote the most diverse
specialized high school but um
the representation for students like
myself as an afro-latino
is like almost zero to none so i think
that like
you know it's common at least for like
um
black students for latinx students to
like
you know gather in different um meetings
and different spaces so for instance
there's like the bsu which is the black
student union
as well as aspira which is um this club
that's
uh quote unquote and investment in
latino youth and latinx youth
and i think that like you know it's a
very alienating it's a very like
lonely space to navigate especially in a
specialized high school with more than
like six thousand plus students
and where you only see a very small
percentage of that six thousand
student mass being students that look
like you
um to add on to that um you know i
never i don't think i can recall or i
can count on the with the fingers on my
hand how many teachers i've had that are
where teachers of color were teachers
that looked like me
and like all of that speaks to the
different um rs and the different
platforms that we work with
i integrate nyc but i feel like you know
i also had privilege
privileges when it came to that so i
went to a new york city specialized high
school so i had access to all the
different aps
i had access to 40 plus sports teams i
had access to like
a whole freaking um plane flight
navigator in
on like in the school building and to
know that like
there's students that don't even have a
cafeteria to sit and have lunch at
there's students that don't have any
access to sports scenes they're students
that you know
there's houseless students there's
students in the foster care system and
like there's
people that are coming from all these
different backgrounds and like
you know to step into a building where
you're already not really welcomed
you're not really represented in the
curriculum i feel like it's something
that we all deal with but like for me
personally like
it's like i go to howard university now
where i have black educators and i learn
about my history and about black history
but
i would have never done that if i had if
it would have been in the new york city
public school system
i would have never had access to these
type of things and i never really had
people that looked like me around me so
i was always like
kind of on my own and like you know
that's like there's
several different instances i can't just
name one where i just felt like
the segregation present but like you
know it's real and then it
exists and like i was going through that
and i didn't realize that i was going
through that at the time until i started
working with integrate nyc
well brian thanks so much for sharing
that i really heard
in his sharing about the experience of
loneliness and the experience
of just um really feeling
torn between trying to get an
opportunity and trying to support your
community and
i'm wondering if anyone else here on the
panel has felt things like loneliness or
feeling torn are there other feelings
that are present for you as young people
who have lived through segregation and
lived through this largest segregated
school system in the united states
yeah i mean it's like the brian was
sharing it's almost hard to kind of just
pinpoint one experience because i think
we grow up in these school systems and
we kind of get so used to being in these
very
um kind of microcosmic environments that
you don't really
necessarily recognize hey like i'm
living in a segregated school system
especially if what you're learning in
school and history
always puts away the focus from new york
city and your experiences
on to the south you know it almost
serves us kind of like this crazy
scapegoat
and that prevents you know often you
know the white history teachers from
looking into themselves in a way that
they also segregate students within
their own classrooms right
um and i guess one thing that i can
share
is i think my school i went to
predominantly black and brown
title one school in brooklyn and one of
you know the things that my school try
to do to give access to a lot of
resources to
its students is kind of send them on
enrichment programs
outside of the school you know so kind
of going to different parts of the city
and engaging in different types of
you know activities and extracurriculars
and that the school just couldn't offer
in-house
and a lot of the times they would send
the students
into very very white and wealthy spaces
um and one that comes to mind is a model
congress that i went to
um around the 10th grade and
it was probably one of the most jarring
experiences that i've ever really had
and because i didn't really know there
were white students
in new york city for a really long time
um
because i grew up like in the little
caribbean like i like went to black and
brown schools
pretty much all my life and so to
then go to a model congress which is
very like a showboating type thing
you know and then to see that like out
of like i don't know
200 300 students my school's the only
delegation
composed of entirely students of color
like it was the most jarring thing to
ever see
and i was often you know the only person
of color like within
just a room you know um and
that is when i started to get hit with
all these classic experiences i'm sure a
lot of people here
would relate to you know the
microaggressions
you know even incidents of just overt
racism
um very gatekeeper-esque language
and things like that and so i think from
there on out i started to become
way more cognizant of just all the
experiences it kind of started to hit me
like
a lot at the same time and it took me
some time to also just heal
from that trauma that i had to injure um
in
in conferences like that from there on
out
um yeah i think it's um
a really interesting question i think
like we're constantly living
in a segregated society right so even if
like
some of us have graduated high school i
think all of us have
um like we still stepped into
um most of us are like stepping into um
segregated higher education institutions
and even like outside like
education institutions like we do live
um
in a in a segregated um
space i guess um and it is challenging
i feel like um
throughout the time and throughout our
work like we
we've gained like the the language to
like maybe like tell our story and like
be like
okay this is happening and like how to
name that
um and that has like in itself been like
hard like learning how to like name like
your story and how to like
like tell it it's like a real process
and
um i think like we also feel like a lot
of
imposter syndrome like even in our
organizing spaces i feel like maybe
that's like
the loneliest i've ever heard like felt
like when imposter syndrome kind of
starts creeping in and like
there's not like one time that happened
and then that's it i feel like
i have it has happened throughout my
life um
where like um i just you feel like
because of who you are like you don't
you don't belong in that space or like
you look around you or or um in my
particular experience like
i was always like how they say like
cherry picked to be in like
ap classes or like honor classes and
like
um it was always like a jarring
experience to like look around you and
see like only like
like one other person or two other
people that like look like you
um and i feel like even in organizing
right like
i remember when we first started out
integrating nyc like
we did like this video project type of
thing and um
i i started this work with like um
my white peer who also went to the same
school as i did and i remember like
we were both in the video and then like
when we um
came out of that like we were standing
together but people were like going up
to her and asking her
questions about like what segregation
means and like what integration mean and
what and what like integrating ways he
is about and so like
i feel like it's really like it can be
like lonely to see
how um how
maybe like people perceive you i don't
know about lonely but it's just like
exhausting you know and like
although we are activists and we're
organizers like we can't constantly be
having
like the energy to have like to stop and
like have a conversation with someone
and like
try to change their whole perspective so
i think like um
learning how to like build our
boundaries and or
like me like learning how to build my
boundaries has like been
um really important and like not having
like those like lonely moments or like
imposter syndrome moments and like
knowing that like
i don't have to be perfect and also that
like my community is here with me
um i'm still trying to like formulate a
response to that question because it
definitely
but like a lot to process and think
about
and i feel like in my organizing
experience i didn't necessarily feel
loneliness
um throughout my entire k through 12
experience i only really existed in
spaces that were predominantly black
and latinx students um so i definitely
didn't feel that sense of isolation in
terms of my race or ethnicity
um but i feel like a lot of what i had
to experience related to organizing was
definitely unpacking um
things like internalized racism um
internalized sexism and other
traumas that come with being a member of
a bipod group
um and that in itself has been extremely
uncomfortable and i remember like
when i first started teams take charge
was often questioning my commitment
um and questioning like whether or not
this was a
mission that i could get behind but i
realized that that process mostly is
about
kind of self-exploration and
self-discovery um and it also definitely
connected to feelings of fear whenever i
did like publish things or like spoke in
public to people
um because like once you say something
or it's out in the world you can't
necessarily take that back
um so like feeling having to feel like
affirmed and confident in what i was
saying and
believing in myself in terms of that um
but yeah sorry if the response was like
unclear i'm still trying to like think
about it
i feel like that was so powerful what
you just said
um especially the piece about not being
able to take it back and taking that
risk every time so
thank you for taking the risk again here
on this panel i appreciate you
matt i was wondering as these incredible
organizers were speaking
what stood out to you the most and
what's a question you have for them or
something that
you think is just really worth elevating
because i feel like they said
so much and i'd love to hear just what's
going on for you
yeah um i mean there's a dozen things i
mean one of the first ones is just
thinking about how
this doesn't stop after high school or
saying all of you are in
college up and i don't know where
everyone's at bank probably mostly
primary
institutions uh i'm a dartmouth i'm a
full professor and encounter a lot of
the same things that you all are
describing
um and that's what you're talking about
um sort of feeling like your cherry
picked to sort of be one of the handful
people like that
that's verbatim the experience of most
faculty of color right
at these these institutions now um and i
think when you sort of think about what
it means to
sort of the reality of segregation means
that you're constantly encountering
people who
um are discovering these things anew for
the first time i think that's part of
the
summer of 2020 right it's for a lot of
people it was um eye-opening experience
but sort of the depths of racism depths
of police brutality
um for a lot of communities of color it
was another summer um
and so i think that's strikes me the
importance of kind of trying to teach
and
um bring these stories to the forward
the thing i'd love to
know more from you all is um there's a
question in the in the chat from
um alex
what teachers can do to support teen
activists um so i
in you i see a lot of my own students of
color here on campus so
could you reflect on for your thing
about yourselves in high school think
about yourselves now in college
what does it mean for um when you're
working with teachers what would you
like to see teachers do
in the classroom support you either in
terms of how they're structuring
uh lessons or teaching about history
what histories would have helped you to
know
when you were in junior high high school
or just in terms of structuring
conversations and
making space for centering your voices
and your experiences
i would love to learn from you as an
educator
i guess i can go um i mean that's a
loaded question
i guess um kind of one of the best
things that i had like when i was
organizing um
in high school there were definitely um
people
in my school that were not in full
support of
um everything that i was doing with um
my
colleagues at teens take charge and
integrate nyc and that was probably
one of the most mentally taxing things
to have to go through
um when you are kind of
in the authority of somebody else who
clearly is not in support
um which is also just very jarring for
me to see because
um like a lot of people mentioned you
know you're often in these primarily
black and brown schools where
teachers who are bearing dominant
identities
um and i guess the biggest thing that
teachers
did for me that were supporting me were
just
settling time to talk and just talk
through um emotions things that you're
feeling checking in on you
um and i think of course like being you
know lenient on like
certain types of things or like you're
also emotional capacity and just
passing on their wisdom as well
especially teachers of color who
have to also um
deal with people who are above them in a
sense um
with their jobs and but also have to
manage their own emotional
um kind of states when they're working
in institutions like this
um and i guess the biggest um kind of
thing that i can say
is just also be open to learn i think a
lot of
um places that i you know have been a
student in
there's almost this kind of like teacher
student dynamic where the teacher feels
like they just have to
you know inculcate everything they know
into the student
and you miss a lot of um you know value
in the student's experience i think
um learning should be a two-way street
um
the teacher should also be the student
and the student should also be the
teacher
and honoring that you don't have to
relate to every single experience your
teach
your student has right and so kind of
guiding that as well
thanks so much i know that we're gonna
now open it up to
our um audience here because we have
about hopefully like 100 students
parents organizers in the audience whose
voices we'd love to hear as well
um and so i'd love to elevate some of
their questions
here um
[Music]
i believe okay
we have a question here which
is um specifically looking
at white parents in school districts
i know that there's an organization
represented here that's working to also
organize white parents and i know matt's
book
speaks specifically about the resistance
of white parents and
y'all have really talked about the
microaggressions that you've experienced
um what are what are some actions that
you think
white parents and white students can
take as allies
in this work um if you were to um
talk about what allyship looks like and
if allyship isn't enough what being a
co-conspirator
looks like
um i think this is also a really
interesting question
uh i think i i was gonna say this with
the teacher questions who i think like
the first most important thing
um to do is to listen like we can sit
here and tell y'all
our experiences and like what our
teachers might have done or like what
our
white allies might have done but this
comes from like our community so i think
like
first thing is to like really listen um
to what your community is saying and to
like what your
young people are saying um or the young
people in
in your spaces are and then like
sort of be brave with that um
especially if you hold like a position
where
um you have like institutional power or
like
like any type of power where like people
are listening to you because like
a lot of the times administration is not
listening to students so i think it's
really important to like
be brave with young people a lot of time
i hear that like
um young people are like organizers
because they're not like afraid
because like we don't have anything to
lose but i think we're like
we fight really hard because we have
everything to lose um
so i think but i think like being brave
with us right like like
um not just listening to us and like
making a space for us like
i think um something that that might one
of my
um teachers in my school did and what i
wish like the white parents
um and like the way students in my
school would have done is like
take um like have meetings with my
principal like i think like
one of those like the like yeah so so
my teacher had like we all had like a
like a meeting with with our principal
it was like the respectful coalition in
my school and
my my teacher she was she's equadorian
like me and she was like the first
ecuadorian
and latina teacher that i i ever had um
in my educational career and she just
like she was brave for us like you know
like like we said like all of these
things are missing and
and she she voiced that to us to our
principal and like our principal didn't
even really have like the words although
he like made excuses but
that like taking a stance is really
important um and like taking like
up that space that you know you can take
up to have the conversations that we're
saying need to happen
um is really important and sort of like
taking like giving back power
to like you know it doesn't belong to
you like give back the power
to like the young people
yeah um i definitely want to underscore
annette's point about amplifying work
that already exists um and work being
done by primary stakeholders of the
issue
um and i think also it's really
important to make a distinction between
allyship and then like performative
allyship um and i personally define
performative allyship as people who kind
of just engage
within social justice work just for like
popularity
um or likes on instagram and i guess to
come
combat that is definitely making sure
your interactions within
um organizing spaces are meaningful and
intentional um
and you're kind of just really engaged
in what's happening and also
committing um and kind of just being
there at your
your full capacity at all times um
someone wants to
elaborate on that thanks diana
um this is a question for matt from the
audience could you please situate the
youth of color in the 1960s
did they form independent and distinct
groups in this movement
even if in partnerships with adults
yes so the um there's multiple different
uh
forms organizing some um kind of more
clearly codified so
youth councils with the nwcp and with
other organizations
and then there were more kind of
informal organizing that would happen at
the high school level
where people just kind of recognize that
this was something that was that they
want to take action on
so it happened both sort of just
inter within youth and then more kind of
intergenerational with with parents as
well
i'm sometimes organized around churches
and other civic organizations
um i think the important thing was that
it was
consistent ongoing organization um
from young people it was it was creative
it was um relentless um like a lot of
the organizing today
um and it was widespread across across
the city right so you don't get 460 000
students to stay out of school without a
huge amount of coordination and without
people
um uh really dedicating themselves to
that
uh to that to that work i'm saying that
those are kind of connections between
uh then and now you know i'd also like
to pop in here to
an ad that what we understand to be
integration when we look retrospectively
back you know when annette's saying
we don't want to focus just on the
movement of bodies right
so something that we did the five-point
platform on real integration i'm sure
anyone here who's seen a pamphlet or
read a book about the black panthers or
the young lords
knows about a multi-plot a multi-point
platform by youth of color
we studied the young lord's uh platforms
we studied the black panthers
when we were doing the 5rs and so i just
want to name that because when our
students were reclaiming
integration and reclaiming what real
integration was
it wasn't that they were making that up
they were integrating youth movements
over the course of time
and the young lords and the black
panthers have been historically
criminalized
and situated as um i think
not not situated in the same way as
integration organized or situated as
some sort of controversial
groups and something that we've tried to
make very clear
is that the black panthers and the young
lords are as controversial
as folks who are organizing for
traditional forms of integration
there are benefits and disadvantages to
all of the different platforms
and so that's been something that we've
been making sure
um to name i'd love to end today's panel
we're
we're mostly organizers and activists
here and so i'd love to end today's
panel with
um a call to action for folks
and so i just love um if all our
participants could just like ground
themselves
and and listen in and tune in and really
believe in reciprocity in the movement
and so
each of our students here um and
hopefully matt and mira
will share one kind of action that they
think you can take
to elevate their work excuse me or to
elevate the movement for school
integration
and i'd ask each participant to just
pledge in the chat
what they're going to do um and so i'm
going to first
um hand it over to teens take charge
who has a summit this weekend um you all
want to share a little bit about that
yeah um so team state charge is um
planning
a nationwide summit um on saturday
um with um we're calling it activist x
academics um which is really a
partnership between
um activists in new york city um as well
as
academics across um the country
um and so we have people like gary
orfield um
coming up to speak with us we have um
joanne boyce
who is moderating um a panel with the
wonderful tiffany and sophie i don't
know if you've
read their work before and so uh thank
you sarah for putting
um the registration link in the chat so
yeah please check it out um
and feel free to look um and see if this
is something you'd be interested in it's
completely um free for youth
and then we're asking for adults if you
can donate whatever you can
to support the youth activists that are
going to be on these panels
thanks so much alex um i'm also going to
just share a quick intro to integrate
and then we're going to dive into
actually a very yale centered
opportunity here with one of our
organizers but integrated nyc
we are always looking just like team
stick charge shared
up for resources and expertise and
networks
to elevate and support our student
organizers and this is a university
just teaming with resources so if you
have a resource a network an idea
please i ask that you click that link
and you send us a contact
um you send us an email in our contact
and share it with us
takes about 30 seconds but could really
make a difference but now this is a
really
exciting opportunity i'm going to hand
it over to annette and o'brien
who are going to elevate one of our
youth organizers who's actually a
student here at yale
who's building out a university network
to bring grassroots movements
to the university space just like matt
said is so needed
so annette o'brien you want to share a
little bit about that opportunity
yeah for sure um well it's currently in
the works is um
called integrate u which is being
spearheaded by joaquin soto
he's a currently a first-year student
here at yale
and um the project is basically aiming
to uplift and integrate nyc's youth
develop frameworks and to further
contribute their
um integration initiatives at the
university level
and it's really about creating like a
networking level
across educational platforms and really
working to like you know
move around resources and build
collaboration and contact
um and if you guys are interested in
working that out please reach out to
joaquin i know we can also put his email
in the chat but um integrate you was the
next big thing
i'm going to put um hawking's info in
the chat
um anything else folks here that we'd
like to plug
all right so what i'd like to do um in
the way that we end all of our meetings
um in most intergenerational organizing
spaces
is just an opportunity um for
acknowledgement
and so um i can start with acknowledging
someone
um and then have them um pop over to
someone else
i want to first acknowledge ayanna ayan
i loved
your comment about not being able the
risk of not being able to take something
back
um and what a risk that is for young
people who are navigating the media and
sharing their story
so popcorning an affirmation to you and
asking you to pick it up and affirm
someone here
and folks in the chat if you could
affirm someone too in the chat that
would be great
yeah um i think i want to
affirm a nut because i feel like i
really resonated with her experience
particularly
um the classroom connections type thing
that's something i participated in when
i was in high school too and i found it
really informative so it's always nice
meeting people with shared experiences
and in general um i feel like if like
she weren't participating it'd be really
hard for me to formulate my own
responses and i feel like i
took a lot of inspiration um from her
responses so
i'll popcorn it to her next
um thank you so much ayanna um
shout out to you as well and shout out
to all the panelists because like
um i was gonna yeah i was gonna shout
out orion acknowledge your brian
specifically because i feel like you
made the most faces
but everyone in this space and all of
your faces and reactions like really
like i'm
such a relationship scout so making
seeing that i could like
make y'all laugh or like just get a
reaction because i really felt connected
um
in this virtual setting so thank you for
being in the space with me
and i'll pass it to ryan
oh thank you i feel gassed um i want to
acknowledge alex i think that
alex did a would like powerfully convey
like
every single idea like when i was
answering the question i was like
damn i just like perfectly said that and
i wish i would have like went after
because then
maybe i could have stolen a little bit
of information and inspiration from
alex so i'll popcorn it to alex
oh thank you brian um yeah i guess um
i guess my um affirmation goes to matt
thank you for bringing this kind of
academic
um perspective in all of this especially
kind of helping us
uncover um the untold um
story is about school integration i
think it's much much needed especially
when talking about
how kind of all the issues in american
life is kind of highlighted on the south
when oftentimes it's really just looking
at yourself and your own privileges and
and the regions that you are in
um that really kind of can foster the
most change so
thank you for bringing that perspective
on this panel
thanks alex um when i complete all my
fellow panelists i've been following
uh the work that um teen shake charge
and nyc have been doing uh from from far
via social media and
online so it's a pleasure to have a
chance to talk with all of you
um i want to thank mira for bringing
everyone together and sarah for doing
such a great job of moderating
i think the specific one um um o'brien i
think what
you were saying about sort of going to a
school into recognizing sort of the
access you had to certain things
while also recognizing the sort of vast
inequalities across the system really
resonate with me and just how
we're always kind of positioned in these
vast networks of
privilege inequality in ways that aren't
fully under our control but we
try to navigate them and change them for
the better um so thanks sarah popcorn
back to you now
thank you all and mira appreciate you
for creating this space
um you know and that talked about being
brave and creating spaces that
haven't been done before um and so
building out spaces for
activists to create research
and create panels and to be honored at
the
in the same space as folks who are seen
as scholars regardless of educational
access
is important and so thank you for being
part of organizing this it took weeks
months um so appreciate y'all so folks
have a beautiful evening and i ask
everyone all participants please
attend teen sick charges summit this
weekend
contact integrate nyc with a resource
concept idea and please please please if
you are a yale student reach out to
joaquin soto
and be a part of bringing this work to
yale university
have a beautiful evening